it's fantastic I love it like totally
blissed out with this it really feels
like the perfect way to have a bite of
Vancouver I'm in Vancouver and it's my
first time in Canada I'm so excited to
be here I'm meeting up with my friend
pearl who runs the Instagram pearl the
foodie she's gonna show me all around
the city I'm gonna try poutine for the
first time we're going to her favorite
ramen spot and then we're gonna have a
meal on top of the mountain let's go
meet her so nice to see you welcome to
Vancouver thank you so much so here
we're at Granville Island one of the
most popular places in Vancouver
it looks so vibrant there's so much
going on yeah I'm so excited for you to
be here so the first place I want to
bring you to is edible Canada okay let's
go hi I'm Eric Bateman president and
founder of edible Canada right here on
Granville Island in beautiful British
Columbia edible Canada is a group of
companies that has restaurants retail
stores and a culinary Travel Division
all focused on showcasing the best of
Canada one of our signature dishes his
bison poutine
comes from Quebec it's cheese curds
gravy on top of french fries we do a
couple fried eggs on top and you break
the yolks and that yolk sort of runs all
through the dish and you got that with
the cheese and we think of Canada we
think of Canadian cuisine we think of
food in the hands of many cultures and
obviously bison was one of the first
things to roam this country so this is
really all about the ultimate Canadian
comfort food I mean this looks crazy
Wow first time driving bison I mean I've
heard of the lean meat but the gravy I
was worried that are gonna make surprise
too soggy but it's actually like the
perfect consistency the egg yolk what is
this makes it more creamy I like how it
has like a meaty texture and it's a
clean so I was already kind of indulgent
so if you had like lean meat kind of
balances like so also these crispy
onions on top it's just like elevates it
a little more is it a little bit of it
Chris yeah I can imagine that like on a
cold winter Canadian night this is
exactly what you want so their first
time having bison Spain what do you
think about it I love it this is the
perfect way to start my first day in
Canada thank you so much I would love to
go explore the rest of the market to
like what else is here yeah okay cool
we're about to go any Brandel public
market what's your favorite song and
their seafood the oysters are really
good oh my god
[Music]
we're on the suspension bridge how far
off the ground is about 450 so we're in
this beautiful forest now it's all nice
here and it's like really good to come
over here just to relax and everything
you just like take a break from like the
city light so I truly think that this is
one of BC's biggest gems everyone's
enjoying it and just so blown away by
how beautiful this is
[Music]
so we're coming to the maratona in
Vancouver and this is actually one of my
favorite moment places in town and I
always bring my friends here also looks
like it
[Music]
hi my name is Todd sushi Koizumi I'm a
director of American ramen Canada mara
Tama is the ramen joint we started the
business from 2001 from Japan and came
to Canada 2013 our signature ramen is a
tam agreement some people recognize
lemon using that whole day but our
signature dish chicken broth we make
everything in the house which is
including the noodles the ramen noodle
made from flowers and lime water to make
the noodle as a Chinese noodle has more
texture chewiness we mix the dough and
we let it stay and flatten the dough and
cut the noodle a simple but dedicated
process to make it our ramen is pretty
simple
the blouson noodle of course and the
Cheshire meat which is simmered for more
than three hours so tender and juicy I
will say seaweed it's a type of the CV
and it gives the hint of a sea food
raver and people love the egg half runny
yolk inside and my net with the soy base
that's amazing when customers come to
your restaurant our staff the welcome
them in Japanese very rush a massage so
giving them more the warm feeling and
once customer getting in they can see we
make the noodle in the open kitchen our
signature is skin gloss the people
notice that it's more delight but
comfortable face a few days later people
exclaiming Evelyn and again
beautiful it smells so good it's like a
chicken is hugging yeah it's amazing
like perfect for the winter yes
and so in Japan that's actually
respectful to slurp iru yes this is
really really really good the broth is
creamy its flavorful it's really rich
but it's really red you don't really
like because of the chicken it doesn't
feel too happy well I got a pork tongue
katsu situation can sometimes feel a
little overpowering I definitely find
that out a lot of ramen places after you
finish eating it you feel kind of
because it's two of it for this one it's
still equally rich and creamy but it
still it's quite light so you feels good
afterwards also the handmade noodles are
so so good they have the right amount of
spring you have to try the egg it's
marinated on the outside but it's also
marinated in the inside so you can taste
the soy sauce flavor and the yolk oh boy
this is an exceptional bullet level it's
almost as if like you teleported to
Japan but you're still in Vancouver
which is something I think we're really
lucky about we're in Vancouver cook
we're really multicultural and we're
blessed with all these like Japanese
Chinese they're kicking it at it
so we're here today at craftsman for the
VIP experience and I'm super excited to
try to we're in a forest how are we
getting to the top of this massive
mountain so people usually hike up there
it's gonna take a couple of hours
depending how good you are but whereas
you can take the gondola okay gondola
feels like a much better idea for us
[Music]
it's hard to imagine that there's a
restaurant at the top of this massive
Merrigan but I can't wait to see
[Music]
so this is one of the most exquisite
dining places in Vancouver and there's
so many activities to do you can look at
berries you can go snowboarding or
skiing in the winter I've never eaten
anywhere like this this is so so cool
hello my name is Dino Gazzola I'm the
food and beverage director here at
Grouse Mountain resorts in North
Vancouver British Columbia the
observatory is our fine dining
restaurant showcasing the best of what
we offer here in BC local organic
sustainable cuisine you look at the
setting we have it's absolutely
exemplary up here everything that we
produce here you can basically see out
here in the valley I mean you get a good
overview of where everything comes from
and what we serve here in the
observatory the first course will be a
chilled Sorel and compressed fennel soup
so it's 8:00 with local Sorel that we
get from a farm out in alder goal that
is again comprised with a vegetable
based stock it's garnished with some
lemon verbena yogurt
that's our tapioca Crisp that's
basically just dehydrated tapioca pearls
it really just speaks of what's local
what's fresh and usually in season it's
a great dish it's chilled it encompasses
everything BC and it works well this
time of year oh it's so bright and it
looks so vibrant oh really refreshing
you know sorrel it kind of has this like
citrusy notes it feels almost like a
smoothie but in a savory way you know
they've got this great tapioca puff so
there's just a little crunchy yeah the
little crunchy element with this like
smooth soup it kind of ties it all in in
this really interesting way and I think
it really breaks up the texture you get
more like different layers of texture in
it I feel like this is a really good way
to open up your appetite before the meal
definitely that'll be followed by a
organic grain fed Flatiron steak the
steak is a Flatiron steak that we
sourced from two rivers meet so it's
taken from the shoulder blade basically
up of cattle gentle prepped is just to
peel potato that we poached it first in
duck fat and that point there we're just
gonna sear it off get some color to it
and then finish it off in the oven so
just a simple preparation for the
accompanying vegetables just a little
butter and those are just juvenile
vegetables from BC it's getting a lot of
that nice sort of brown butter over the
vegetables that's another level of
flavor to it so I'll give that one last
hard sear at that butter in there
and the butter will start to brown
you'll get better nice base that's
served with a parsnip puree potato Fond
all kale from our garden and then the
last component is the bone marrow juice
so that's a veal stock that we make
in-house we then reduce that veal stock
down with lots of aromatic vegetables
and herbs and lots of red wine I really
love the dish I mean it could really got
some really nice flavor to it I has a
really nice texture you really get that
duck fat flavor coming through the
potato it's really nice to have these
fresh vegetables along with something
heavier like a duck fat potato and it
kind of makes it feel like a more
balanced meal it's like a whole complete
perfect set totally the meat is
perfectly cooked
there's you all around it which is the
ante of reduction everything feels like
buttery and smooth but then you have the
lightness of vegetables similarly to the
poutine I feel like we could be having
this on a cold Canadian night really
what I love to finish off we're gonna
have a local rhubarb tart so we're just
gonna plate up our rhubarb tart rhubarb
has been slightly poached in the simple
syrup really again brings out some of
the really nice flavors to it and we
further have a garnish of a hibiscus
tuile so that's made with isomalt sugar
which just a modified sugar so it stays
nice and clear and has that really nice
color to it and to finish it off we have
our hibiscus sorbet and candied rhubarb
very few components but nice simple
fresh seasonal we love it it looks like
a work of art it's so delicate Wow
there's so much happening you know
rhubarb can be sometimes a little too
tart this feels perfectly just the right
amount of sweetness I'm a big big fan of
this so this is kind of an example of
what's in season right now there's a lot
of rhubarb desserts in Vancouver
especially in the summer I also love I
mean this like little glassy rhubarb
it's beautiful it's definitely a really
fun piece to eat mm-hmm it looks
beautiful it's like a rhubarb Jolly
Rancher like a really elegant Jolly
Rancher it's like bursting with flavor
it really is this is so lovely I think
this is my favorite course that
I had so many awesome experiences to
choose from in Vancouver and now I get
to choose how to pay for them with pant
planet from American Express I feel so
lucky to have you as my tour guide and
I'm so glad you came to Vancouver to
visit us yeah thank you yes
[Music]
you